[Musique]
alors le concept c'est de pouvoir
proposer aux gens une immersion complète
dans le dans un jeu vidéo donc c'est ils
sont équipés d'un casque de réalité
virtuelle donc ils ont l'arme
aujourd'hui pour l'instant ils ont
encore l'ordinateur sur le dos donc ce
qu'on aura plus dans quelques semaines
et ils sont ils vont évoluer dans un
espace de 500 mètres carrés en évoluant
dans le jeu donc en match soit par
équipe soit en collaboratif soit en
chacun pour soi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est ici au sein de l'Arena Eva à
Maurepas c'est tout nouveau c'est le
premier dans les Yvelines c'est une
activité qui commence à très bien
marcher d'ailleurs
[Musique]
c'est vraiment accessible à tout le
monde que ce soit des joueurs ou des non
joueurs parce que c'est vraiment très
facile d'accès
je suis en train de manipuler
pour aujourd'hui les gens de 15 35 ans
c'est vraiment ils sont nés avec ça quoi
donc voilà même si ça s'adresse à tout
le monde mais en particulier à ce public
là et c'est un des loisirs du futur et
aussi c'est du sport aussi
[Musique]
vous avez été tué par Sabine mais
toujours
ça y est on vient de terminer notre
session d'une heure ici à Maurepas alors
Céline première réaction alors c'est
fatiguant mais on s'est beaucoup amusé
je pense qu'on s'en est bien sorti
certains puisque d'autres d'ailleurs
certains plus que d'autres en tout cas
si vous voulez tester c'est ici à
Maurepas et nous on vous le recommande
on va d'ailleurs continuer un petit peu
l'entraînement allez